typisches gericht ein claudia roth sich
die klamotten weil wieder selbst traut
gelegt hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen beim wahlkampf
und wie begrüßt man sich beim wahlkampf
muss ich sag ja so ein traum geht in
erfüllung
kein schöner traum aber ein freund die
teuer ist so eine einfache fahrt mit dem
bus
ich hab eine monatskarte insofern ist
eine schwierige frage kann sein dass sie
wahrscheinlich zu 60 oder sogar frost
sie müsste ihnen dann jetzt verrechnen
verifizieren meinem online euro oder
beispiel in zwei werden wir zwei euro
fünfzig kinder sind wir raus gehen
nachher
übrigens in ihrem wahlprogramm
da erkenne ich sehr viel hoffnung und
die hoffnung dass ihre wähler dass du
gar nicht lesen werden der die hoffnung
habe ich nicht steuererhöhungen
das wird gerne mal steuersenkungen oder
wie dieser weg ich habe jetzt mal hier
100 euro zeigen sie mir doch mal wie
viel bleibt jetzt ein besserverdiener
die mir denn der macht sind ich vermute
ungefähr die 7 euro 50
die ich vorhin über einen bus tarif
hinaus geblieben da keine nicht erinnern
jetzt könnt ihr trotzdem mit der kamera
bei mir lieber wenn noch die sicherung
für mich oder ich bin gleich lerne ich
muss nur klein
[Musik]
und hände weg vom gegner
obwohl er sich je nach der wahl
kommen wir jetzt zur pantomime eine bei
unseren zuschauern sehr beliebten
problem sei der typische gesicht wenn
die kanzlerin ihn mal wieder ein thema
geklaut hat sein typisches gesagt wenn
claudia roth sich die klamotten weil
wieder selbst drauf gelegt hat
wenn die ergebnisse im september lux
schwarz
es ist wie wenn rot grün im september
jetzt doch die wahl gewinnt keine ahnung
sagt anfrage von bock hat
welchen ministerposten möchte wieder
nach der wahl haben und man soll das
fell des bären verteilen wenn er erlegt
wie aber sollte ein grüner bären erlegen
und fälle verteilen
[Musik]
aussagen man soll den fünften teil
geboren
trittin wir fahren wird mit dem
wahlkampf zu ihrer nächsten
karrierestationen das verfahren vom
finanzministerium oder können sich schon
mal diese pflanze in ihr büro stellt
aber jetzt zu sagen wir werden neue
finanzminister hier
sie würden gern die kopf warnte schon
mal im büro stellen vertreten
hallo denn sonst noch reingekommen und
bei ihm liegen deswegen auch mit die
verabschiedung wie verabschiedet man
sich beim wahlkampf bussi bussi bussi
becker wollte einfach und auf den mund
küssen
ach guck mal papa immer noch den fehler
von trittin
da kommen wir jetzt erstmal ne schöne
topfpflanze führen und damit zurück ins
studio noch eine anzahl heinz die wird
doch immer so lustig